ja wir kommen zur aktuellen sitzung
heute behandeln wir die frage nach
digitalen mündigkeit und digitale
aufklärung wir werden noch genauer sehen
was es damit auf sich hat vor allem mit
unmündigkeit das ist ein wort was man
heute nicht mehr so häufig gebraucht
häufig verwendet mit blick auf kinder
oder
personen die noch nicht ganz zurechenbar
sind die noch nicht richtig ja zur
verantwortung gezogen werden können also
mündigkeit hat immer etwas mit
verantwortung zu tun es geht also
letztendlich auch im digitalen
verantwortung was es damit auf sich hat
werden wir sehen digitale verantwortung
kann man in zweierlei hinsicht verstehen
einmal kann man es verstehen im sinne
der verantwortung
für die digitalisierung also was mit der
digitalisierung gemacht werden kann es
kann aber auch eben verdammt so
verstanden werden dass wir durch die
digitalisierung
neue form von verantwortung auch
entwickeln können also es
digitalisierung durch die verantwortung
durch digitalisierung und verantwortung
für digitalisierung also man kann auch
sicherlich eine digitale aufklärung
betreiben mit digitalen mitteln im
zeitalter der digitalität sie ein
bisschen doppelt deutlich darauf geben
wir heute 1 und wie immer haben wir uns
ein paar fragen überlegt wie wir
benötigen wir überhaupt eine digitale
aufklärung wie könnte eine digitale
unmündigkeit bestehen wie könnte ein
öffentlicher gebrauch der
digitalisierung aussehen wir kommen noch
drauf warum öffentlichkeit hier so
wichtig ist und inwiefern verändert die
digitalisierung unsere lebenswelt
nachhaltig und auch noch eine frage die
zentrales inwiefern verändert die
digitalisierung den menschen das ist
auch ganz wichtig
gehen wir mal auf die digitale aufkleber
ein bisschen mehr ein es gibt ein neues
buch von oc wuchs um tim cole digitale
aufklärung warum uns das internet klüger
machen wir sehen hier am titel hier wird
das digitale schon mal so ein bisschen
eingeschränkt es wird vor allem auf das
internet bezogen man könnte sich jetzt
fragen warum wird das nicht auch auf
computerspiele bezogen oder auf
künstliche intelligenz wir haben ja
gesehen es gibt drei große phänomen
internet künste intelligenz und
computerspiele vielleicht noch was wird
ist aber das sind so die wichtigsten
also man kann ja von vornherein schon
fragen ist hier nicht der fokus nur auf
das internet natürlich wenn man das
internet als virtuellen handlungsraum
von steht sieht man dass da auch
wiederum die anderen groß phänomene mit
rein kommen also computerspiele gibt es
im internet und auch künstliche
intelligenz wird im internet eingesetzt
diese bereiche sind nicht voneinander
klar zu trennen soweit ist das schon
richtig und das verbindende könnte dann
tatsächlich das internet sein was
zwischen den verschiedenen phänomen
bereich eben verbindet jetzt sagen die
autoren folgendes ich bringe jetzt ein
paar zitate die zentral sind sowie
digitalisierung immer beschleunigung
bedeutet bedeutet vernetzung über
veränderungen ich gerade zum wesen der
vernetzung begründet ein gutes beispiel
dafür wie vernetzung zur veränderung
führt stammt von vint cerf einem der
erfinder des tcp ip protokolls das ist
ein wichtiges eine wichtige technologie
für die internetverbindungen und somit
einem der väter des internets was
passiert fragt es wert wenn wir einen
internetfähigen kühlschrank mit einem
ebenfalls internetfähigen personenwagen
vernetzen es verändert sich gepasst sie
kommen abends nach hause und der
kühlschrank ist nicht mehr zu öffnen
oder enthält noch diätkost weil die
beiden sich einig geworden sind dass sie
lieber ein paar tagen abnehmen slogan
das ist jetzt die verbindung durch das
internet natürlich hier im falle dieses
kühlschranks mit hilfe von künstlicher
intelligenz da werden unsere daten und
zur körpergewicht vielleicht auch
sonstige gesundheitsfaktor blutwerte
kann man sich alles überlegen abgerufen
zur information verarbeitet und dann
eben auch ausgegeben
digitalisierung und vernetzung sind alle
die komplementären also die sich
gegenseitig ergänzenden kräfte die die
exponentielle beschleunigung nicht nur
der technologieentwicklung und zur
gesamten lebensweise auf individueller
wie gesellschaftlicher ebene
vorantreiben willkommen in der ad hoc
gesellschaft ad hoc gesellschaft geduld
das alles sofort und unmittelbar
realisierbar wird in dieser digitalen
gesellschaft
durch die vernetzung und die
beschleunigung da sind jetzt also
natürlich ihre soziologische analysen
der digitalisierung nicht im strengen
sinne philosophische aber auch
soziologisch ist es ganz wichtig zu
sehen was ich ändern hinzu kommt noch
das exponentielle wachstum
das hatten wir gesehen anhand des trans
humanismus
ray kurzweil da mache ich auch oben
rechts und links auch da ist die idee
einer exponentiellen technologische
entwicklung ganzer gleitend natürlich
noch verbunden mit dem gedanken eine
singularität die daraus resultiert also
vernetzung beschleunigung exponentielles
wachstum adhoc gesellschaft das wirkt
sich auch auf die gesamte lebensweise
aus und das haben wir ja auch beobachtet
digitalisierung macht vor nichts halt
die betrifft alle bereiche
und im folgenden thesen da sind jetzt
thesen zur aufklärung wollen wir ganz im
geiste der klassischen europäischen
aufgeben ein denkprozess einleiten und
darüber hinaus einen gesellschaftlichen
diskurs anstoßen es geht uns darum dass
neue dass wir hinter dass wir heute
immer kürzeren abständen erleben auch
als etwas wirklich neues zu denken uns
also jenseits herkömmlicher
vorstellungen und begriffe zu bewegen um
so gerüstet in einen gesellschaftlichen
diskurs eintreten zu können auch und
gerade darüber ob und wie uns dieses
neue nützlich sein könnte oder ob wir es
als untauglichen irrweg besser auf die
männer halten der geschichte expedia
soll ganz wichtig an diesem zitat ist
das hier die these vertreten wird es
geht
mit der digitalisierung und etwas neues
und dieses neu dass bob auch neue
begriffe
väter sind wir philosophin und viele
suchen gefragt die zu prägen angemessen
begriffe und hier wird wieder auf eine
soziologische ebene an gespielt nämlich
ein gesellschaftlicher diskurs wie
dieses neu zu bewerten ist wir brauchen
hier auf jeden fall begriffe ja handelt
es sich dabei mal untaugliche weg den
man besser nicht weiterverfolgen sollte
das ist eine spannende frage ich glaube
aber die sache ist schon entschieden bis
mitten auf dem bild der digitalisierung
und da gibt es keinen weg zurück mehr
obwohl wir auch gesehen haben manchmal
so was wie post digital der begriff des
post digital bemüht wird um dieser
entwicklung einhalt zu gebieten
man könnte sagen kostete tal ist immer
auch noch digital also man kann die
entwicklung gar nicht mehr rückgängig
machen so wie man auch die
elektrifizierung nicht mehr rückgängig
machen kann wobei die digitalisierung
daraus natürlich passiert und noch viel
gravierendere folgen hat durch die
vernetzung beschleunigung und das
exponentielle wachstum
jetzt werden die zehn thesen präsentiert
ich möchte ihnen auch mal vorstellen ich
finde ganz wichtig erste these alles was
ich digitalisieren lässt wird
digitalisiert alles was ich vernetzten
letzt wird vernetzt und das verändert
alles
das verändert zumindest alles was sich
digitalisieren letzt hier stellt sich
die frage gibt es dinge die wir nicht
digitalisieren können
wir können sicherlich in der wirtschaft
sehr viele arbeitsprozesse
digitalisieren beschleunigen auch in
körperlichen also die prozesse sind
nicht mehr angewiesen auf die materie
denken sie ein bitcoin und solche dinge
die er gar nicht mehr wirklich an der
materie auf der anderen seite kann man
sich wirklich fragen was letztlich den
bitteschön nicht mehr digitalisieren und
mir könnte man jetzt zunächst auch daran
denkt an den menschlichen geist und
gehirn aber auch das wird ja schon
nachgebildet durch künstliche neuronale
gibt es dann auch wieder oben rechts in
den kreis diese neuronalen netze sind ja
unser gehirn modelliert nachempfunden
die simulieren unser gehirn ob das jetzt
eine position nationen des gehirns ist
oder wirklich eine andere realisierungs
weise das muss einmal dahin gestellt
lassen wir sehen selbst unser gehirn ist
nicht davor gefeit mit der
digitalisierung zu unterliegen
information unserem gehirn lassen sich
ja auch digitalisieren unser gehirn ist
ja ein großes informationsverarbeitung
systems und kann man es beschreiben und
nichts anderes machen ja auch diese
computer namens
nächste these lautet digitalisierung und
vernetzung sind kein stopfen sie gehen
nicht wieder weg dass die frage gibt es
ja einen rückweg gibt es ja ein
zeitalter nach der digitalisierung die
auffassung dieser autoren ist nein
digitalisierung ist gekommen um zu
bleiben genauso wie die elektrifizierung
und alle anderen technologien die wir
uns gar nicht mehr wegdenken können das
kann man sich fragen ja wie sieht es aus
wenn man zum beispiel eine energiekrise
hat wie es gerade der fall zu sein
scheint da müssen wir dann wieder zurück
vor das zeitalter der digitalisierung
das muss man abwarten habe ich glaube
die digitalisierung ist nicht nur etwas
was energie frisst soll was richtig
verwendet auch energie sparen kann wenn
es richtig verwendet hatte und das ist
auch eine frage die in der letzten
sitzung der nächsten sitzung behandeln
müssen digitalisierung und umweltschutz
ja die these dass digitalisierung alles
verändert muss natürlich vor dem
hintergrund diskutiert werden ob dadurch
nicht zu viel energie verbraucht wird
wenn man alles digitalisieren möchte ich
bin da optimistisch ich glaube wenn man
digitalisierung richtig einsetzt dann
kann man sehr sehr viel energie sparen
wie man zum beispiel hand von digitalen
büchern sieht dann die nicht mehr
gedruckt werden müssen mit aufwändig
verfahren papier brauchen wir nicht mehr
und so weiter und so fort auf der
anderen seite müssen digital dinge ja
immer aufrechterhalten werden auch wenn
wir sie nicht
benutzen in der cloud es hat also immer
so einen ganz großen
bereitstellungs aufwand der mit der
digitalisierung hält und das muss man
gegenüber einander abwägen die nächste
these möchte ich auch nicht verschweigen
diese drei die digitale und die reale
welt durchdringen sich immer mehr dass
verendet beide mit rasender
geschwindigkeit in einem bisher
unvorstellbarem
ja das ist die idee auch das hybriden
damit das digitale und das reale das
digital und das analoge würde ich lieber
sagen weil hier schon so ein bisschen
suggeriert wird die nicht digitale bild
sei die eigentliche welt und die
digitale welt sei nicht die reale
da habe ich so ein bisschen bedenken
darüber möchte nur verweisen auf den
begriff der virtuellen realität wir
haben das ausgiebig diskutiert oben
rechts den link dazu wieder dann das
digitale ist eine eigene form von
realität und kann der realen welt so gar
nicht gegenüber gestellt werden das ist
auch meine these also jedenfalls
zuzustimmen ist dass ich hier das
digitale und das analoge würde ich hier
lieber einfügen dass sich die immer mehr
durchdringen und vernetzen sonst war mit
rasender geschwindigkeit
sofern wir genug energie da muss man
dazu sagen
these 4 digitalisierung und vernetzung
schaffen technisch und gesellschaftlich
kulturell und wissenschaftlich neue
bedingungen sie gilt es in kategorien zu
fassen und als qualitäten zu erstehen
erstmal hier der begriff der qualität
man könnte doch denken digitalisierung
hat es nur mit quantitäten zu tun es
geht nur um schneller mehr höher weiter
schneller weiter das sind alles nur
quantitative begriffen hier wird jetzt
dafür argumentiert dass es um qualität
geht also nicht nur schneller weiter
sondern wie eine ganze neue form
stichwort transformation und zwar
verschiedenen bereichen nicht nur
technologisch zum gesellschaftlich
kulturell wissenschaftlich
kulturell finde ich ganz wichtig in der
ästhetik ändert sich einiges wir hatten
es mit computerspielen zu tun gehabt wo
rechts auch der link dazu
die digitalisierung betrifft eben die
gesamte lebenswelt nicht nur die
ökonomie und die
wissenschaft these 5 massenmedien
verlieren mit dieser entwicklung nach
150 jahren ihre gemeinschafts und
identitätsstiftende funktion dadurch
kehrt die kommunikation gewissermaßen zu
ihrem ursprung zurück zum inter
personalaustausch der heute allerdings
zunehmend digital und medial vermittelt
statt dieser these stimmt mich sehr zu
massenmedien herunter sind zum beispiel
die zeitungen zu verstehen die verlieren
ihre bedeutung warum verlieren die ihre
bedeutung weil massenmedien erstmal
nicht mehr dieser rasanten
aktualität damit mithalten können
informationen gleiten reibungslos im
internet sofort wir haben sofort
informationen in echtzeit das können
zeitung nicht leisten herkömmliche weise
ihr es gedruckt werden müssen manchmal
kriegt man die nachrichten dann auch vom
vorherigen abend oder von der nacht wenn
es frühmorgens gedruckt wird aber es
gibt hier immer eine verzögerung der
digitalisierung gibt es keine
verzögerung da gibt es nur echtzeit wenn
sie irgendwie dann auf ihrem smartphone
eine push notification erhalten das
ereignis hat sich dort abgespielt das
ist echt zeit fünf bis zehn minuten
später haben sie das ja und es wird
immer auch eben weiter entwickelt sie
können die informationen permanent
aktuell halten und müssen nicht immer
eine ganze zeitung was ist der
unterschied und es handelt sich
natürlich auch meine individualisierung
der neuen medien wie man zum beispiel
ein phänomen von youtube sieht youtube
bedeutet wie er selbst werde nicht immer
zu rezitieren den konsumenten sondern
wir produzieren auch also der
unterschied zwischen sender und
empfänger der wird so nicht mehr
beizubehalten sein sondern sender und
empfänger tauschen sich aus gesehen da
wird selbst zum empfänger in der
empfänger wird zum sender wie man auf
youtube sieht die hürde eigene inhalte
informationen über das internet zu
tauschen auszutauschen die wird viel
viel niedriger durch die neuen medien
dem stimme ich sehr zu diese sechs
digitalisierung und vernetzung
produzieren eine dramatische
beschleunigung und
disruptive entwicklung von technologien
und medien diese gilt es nicht zu
beherrschen sondern zu verstehen nun zu
genießen also der genuss der
digitalisierung was darunter zu
verstehen also destruktiv bedeutet also
es ändert sich grundlegend
destruktiv bedeutet alte technologien
werden abgelöst und verschwinden in der
geschichte gibt es einfach nicht mehr zu
nennen ist zum beispiel an dem
schriftsetzer beruf wonach mit einzelnen
buchstaben lettern einsatz erstellt
wurde ich glaube es gibt keinen einzigen
sechser mehr vielleicht nur noch im
museum der buchdrucker buch setzer beruf
der start aus weil wir durch die
digitalisierung das alles viel leichter
herstellen können das ist eine
destruktive entwicklung
hier möchte ich ein bisschen kritisch zu
bringen geben wir müssen natürlich auch
die neuentwicklung beherrschen wir
sollten nicht zu optimistisch sein und
glauben dass die neue digitale
entwicklung in sich schon gut sind oder
mit sich nur auf das gute gerichte sind
das ist glaube ich ein fehlschluss
müssen sie verstehen wir müssen sie auch
beherrschen und wir müssen sie natürlich
auch gelesen aber beherrschen bedeutet
immer auch sie kritisch zu reflektieren
hier klingt mir ein bisschen zu sehr
optimismus durch da muss man ein
bisschen kritisch gegen stören these 7
das leben einer derart grundsätzlich
anderen welt wird damit komplexe aber
nicht komplizierter sondern einfach das
einfacher hängt wieder mit dem genießen
zusammen auch in optimismus der sich
dahinter verbirgt ich würde schon auch
sagen dass das leben einer digitalen
bild auch komplizierte werden kann wenn
die technologie nicht richtig eingesetzt
wird es geht immer um die frage wie kann
die technologie die digitale sinnvoll
eingesetzt werden sie kann die sache
auch komplizierter machen wenn die
technik nicht richtig funktioniert wenn
sie nicht annehmbar angenehm gestaltet
ist also hier muss man auch sehr viel
design digital aber dann kann das ganze
prinzipiell auch einfacher werden das
sehen wir durch sehr benutzerfreundliche
software aber auch durch niedrigere
barrierefreiheit die partizipation die
selbstbestimmung der nutzerinnen und
nutzer die wert viel leichter glaubt dem
ist zuzustimmen grundsätzlich these acht
wir sind gleich durch es gibt nur zehn
thesen diese acht auch der mensch und
sein denken verändert sich grundsätzlich
er funktioniert und denkt zunimmt die
die taten von und dass sie rechts hat
dem stimme ich vollkommen zu wir müssen
darüber diskutieren wie verändert sich
der mensch durch die digitalisierung
thema anthropologie
echtzeit er denkt digital was heißt denn
digital denken was heißt denn das
spannende frage ich möchte hier lieber
den begriff des virtuellen spiel bringt
weil digital denken würde bedeuten die
nun einzeln zu denken und so denkt man
nicht man denkt nicht nur 1 oder 0 ja
oder nein sondern denkt in größeren
zusammenhängen wahrscheinlich ist dass
damit gemeint das vernetzte denken den
würde ich natürlich total zustimmen hier
ist das thema hypertext er wieder
zentral also die verlinkung die
verknüpfung wie man sie zum beispiel auf
wikipedia sieht wie kitas wiki denken
möchten und das in echtzeit genau also
man kann hier wirklich
denken echtzeit und zwar mit anderen
nicht zu denken diese neuen begriffe und
erfahrung aus der analogen vergangenheit
werden dieser sich dynamisch
weiterentwickeln und gegenwart immer
weniger gerecht sie willigen der
aktuellen debatte ebenso naiv wie
unpassend oder überheblich in jedem fall
aber hilflos stimme ich zu wir brauchen
neue begriffe und wir sollten hier nicht
so sehr aus der analogen vergangenheit
schöpfen wir sollten uns darauf beziehen
sollten aber nicht künstlich das neue
mit alten begriffen versuchen zu
verstehen so verlieren wir den zugang
auf das wirklich neue und veränderte die
neuen chancen sie sich dadurch bieten
und die letzte these und das ist jetzt
der bezug zur heutigen sitzung wir
brauchen eine digitale aufklärung neu
und selbst gedacht die kategorien die
allein dieser grundsätzlich veränderten
welt gerecht werden können nur damit
können wir diese welt kritisch
reflektieren und produktiv nutzen dem
stimme ich vorbehaltlos zu neu und
selbst gedacht die kategorien die dieser
neuen welt veränderten welt gerecht
werden können und hier auch kritisch
reflektieren produktiv nutzen genau
nicht nur optimistisch sind auch schauen
was für schattenseiten gehen wir
digitalisierung her stichwort gar nicht
spielt wird das digitale böse oben
rechts machen link wieder rein auch
diese phänomene sollten wir bei allem
techno optimismus nicht aus dem blick
verlieren
so viel zu den tc thesen die ich für
sehr anregend wert finde auch wenn ich
bei der eine ganze natürlich etwas
einzuwenden hatte
und jetzt würde hier der bogen
geschlagen auf die aktuelle frage nach
der aufklärung und auf ihre historische
bedeutung in einer ähnlichen situation
des fundamentalen wandels befanden sich
die menschheit schon einmal gegen ende
des 18 jahrhunderts der staat die
gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen
verhältnisse wurden über den haufen
geworfen dass zwischen klassische logik
und mittelalterliche schloss sich
gefangen mitdenken war hoffnungslos
überfordert von der gegenwärtigen
dynamik der veränderung angesichts
dieses klassischen telemaz bestand
immanuel kant das ist jetzt der
historische bezugspunkte manuel kahns
antwort in seiner maxime jederzeit
selbst zu denken ist die aufklärung vor
der gleichen aufgabe stehen wir heute
mit der digitalen ich finde in bezug zu
kann sehr sehr wichtig und möchte jetzt
ein bisschen was über kant sagen was
sagt erkannt und bauaufklärung er sagt
in seiner schrift beantwortung der frage
was ist aufklärung von 1784 sind kann
das sicherlich schon mal alle gehört
aufklärung ist der ausgang des menschen
aus seiner selbstverschuldeten
unmündigkeit
unmöglichkeit ist das unvermögen sich
seines verstandes ohne leitung eines
antritt zu bedienen selbst verschuldet
ist diese unmündigkeit wenn die ursache
sei nicht ein mangel des verstandes sind
die entschließung und des modus legt
sich seiner ohne leitung eines anderen
zu bedienen sapara audi habe mut dich
deines eigenen verstandes zu bedienen
ist also der wahlspruch der aufklären
also die unmündigkeit die ist nicht
einfach ein schicksal wie man den könnte
jetzt ist halt nun mal die
digitalisierung so weit fortgeschritten
da können wir gar nichts machen da
bleibt uns gar nichts anderes übrig als
ja irgendwie ja frustriert dann
irgendwie sich weg begeben sondern
aufklärung ist immer auch deswegen nötig
weil wir selbst schuld sind wir haben
uns selbst
wir haben selbst die situation
geschaffen aus der wir uns durch die
aufklärung wieder herausarbeiten müssen
wir haben eine unmündigkeit erzeugt und
eine verdunklung erzeugt das ja diese
metapher der aufklärung also aufgehen
ist eine allegorie dann auf eine
metapher meteorologische metapher wonach
die sonne verdeckt worden ist durch
keine wolke und es dadurch dunkel wurde
was wurde dunkel unser verstand
natürlich nur haben wir eben den
verstand selbst verdunkelt das ist der
entscheidende punkt und dass es die
selbstverschuldete unmündigkeit und
jetzt müssen wir uns eben wie das selbst
mit unseren verstand aus dieser
verdunklung heraus arbeiten und das ist
nichts anderes als die aufklärung jetzt
kann man das natürlich auf die digitale
situation beziehen ich möchte aber
trotzdem noch mal von kanne paar sachen
vorlesen faulheit und feigheit sind die
ursachen warum ein so großer teil der
menschen nachdem sie natur längst und
fremder leitung frei gesprochen dennoch
gerne zeitlebens unmündig bleiben und
warum es anderen so leicht wird sich zu
deren formen aufzuwerfen es ist so
bequem wie möglich zu sein habe ich ein
buch das für mich verstand hat ein
seelsorger der für mich gewissen hat ein
arzt der vermisste die beurteilt und so
weiter so brauche ich mich nicht selbst
zu bemühen ich habe nicht möglich zu
denken wenn ich nur bezahlen kann andere
werden das vertriebs nicht geschäft
schon für mich übernehmen ganz
interessant des geld bezahlen das medium
des geldes ist auch eine form der
unmündigkeit weil ich alles delegieren
kann durch geld kann ich mich bequem
einrichten und das denken das soll
betragen für mich anderen personen
betragen und das ist eine
selbstverschuldete unmündigkeit
das ganze kann man jetzt natürlich auch
vor allem durch das digitale die
digitale medien
aktualisieren zb habe ich ein internet
das für mich verstand hat
habe ich eine app und so weiter und so
fort das internet kann auch so ein
bisschen als
medium der möglichkeit verstanden werden
ich muss ja selbst nicht mehr denken das
internet enthält ja alle
gedanken schon heute brauche ja noch
ganz zu konsumieren das wäre so eine
digitale unmöglichkeit bekommt gleich
noch darauf zu sprechen er sagt noch ein
zitat es ist also für jeden menschen
schwer aus dem beinahe zur natur
gewordenen unmöglichkeit sich
herauszuarbeiten
er hat die sogar lieb gewonnen und ist
von der hand wirklich unfähig seines
eigenen verstandes zu bedienen weil man
ihn niemals den versuch davon machen die
satzungen und formeln diese mechanische
werkzeuge wenn es die gebrauchs- oder
vielmehr missbrauch seiner tour gaben
sind diffus schellen einer
immerwährenden
unmündigkeit wer sie auch ab würde würde
dennoch auch über den schmalsten graben
einer unsicheren sprung provider zu der
gleichen stein bewegung nicht gewöhnt
ist daher gibt es nur wenige dem es
gelungen ist durch eigene bearbeitung
ihres geistes nicht aus der unmündigkeit
heraus entwickeln und der noch einen
sicheren gang zu tun also satzungen
formeln wir sollten keine mechanischen
werkzeuge unseres unserer vernunft
verwenden da ließe sich natürlich sofort
auch eine digitalisierung denken wir
sollen die digitalisierung nicht als
mechanisches werkzeugs entstehen wir
müssen hier aufpassen dass wir uns nicht
unfrei machen und unmündig werden durch
die digitalisierung das ist eben sehr
wohl möglich und zum schluss sagt kannte
diese aufklärung wird nichts erfordert
als freiheit und zwar die
unterschiedlichste und allem was eine
freiheit heißen mag nämlich die dann
seiner vernunft in allen stücken
öffentlichen gebrauch zu machen
öffentliche gebraucht das ist jetzt hier
das entscheidende
wir wollen uns jetzt fragen wie kann man
jetzt in der digitalen sphäre
öffentlichen gebrauch der vitalen
vernunft machen
dazu wollen wir uns jetzt erstmal fragen
worin besteht eigentlich die digitale
unmöglichkeit wir hatten schon nach kant
gesehen was unmündigkeit in seiner zeit
analoge unmündigkeit gewissermaßen war
jetzt geht es um digitale unmündigkeit
eine form wäre zum beispiel wir nehmen
alle informationen in für bare münze wir
fallen auf fake news rein weil wir zu
unkritisch sind gegenüber dieser
informationsflut die wir da beziehen
können weiterer punkt wäre wir begreifen
die entwicklung der digitalisierung als
ein rein technologisch ist als wir
verstehen mich die digitalisierung als
was du jedes weltliches sondern
überlassen dass einzelne experten
experten oder unternehmen die dann
bestimmen welche medien wir überhaupt
zur verfügung haben was wir im internet
tun können wir verwenden die
digitalisierung zum zweck der bloßen
simulationen stichwort computerspiele
benutzen die digitalisierung nur um eine
scheinwelt zu erzeugen mit der wir uns
die wir uns flüchten
wir verwenden die digitalisierung nur
als ein hilfsmittel da würden aber viele
schon sagen das ist doch gerade
aufklärung durch wird sagen nein das ist
nicht aufklärung digitalisierung sollten
wir nicht mehr als ein hilfsmittel nicht
nur als instrument gebrauchen warum
nicht weil wir dann immer noch abhängig
werden von diesen hilfsmitteln und alles
nur objektivieren ich werde darauf noch
genauer eingehen er verwende
digitalisierung als hand kommt zu medium
internet computerspiele das hängt auch
mit der simulation das haben wir werden
nur abhängig das ist das was kann sagte
wir haben doch eine eine zeitung wir
haben doch alles wir können doch alles
lesen das buch das nimmt uns doch dass
selbst denken da würde ich sagen es noch
viel gefährlicher im internet das
internet in ganz auch unser selbst
denken habe weil es hier so viele
informationen gibt und wir eben auch
dann in solche babbels geraten solche
blasen youtube schlägt uns nur die dinge
vor die wir überhaupt wissen
wollten und dann
drehen wir uns im virtuellen digitalen
kreis ja also babbel bildung
blasenbildung ist noch viel viel
schlimmer im internet was die
unmündigkeit anbelangt das ist ein
problem wir unterscheiden nicht zwischen
simulationen physische realität
das betrifft hier bitte diesen dritten
punkt nach der simulation
wir sollten immer wissen was wird
simuliert und was es wirklich also
simulationen realität und das ist jetzt
meine these wie unterscheide nicht
zwischen simulation und virtuelle
realität
häufig wird zwischen beiden nicht
unterschieden als ein computerspiel wenn
wir den microsoft flight simulator
spielen ein flugsimulator
computerspiel dann würden viele sagen
das ist virtuelle realität wir befinden
uns hier in der virtuellen realität wir
sehen hier von oben new york fliegen mit
dem flugzeug nieder wir fliegen durch
die häuser das können wir vielleicht gar
nicht wirklichkeit tun dann wird es
schon ein bisschen fiktionale nicht nur
simuliert ich glaube das ist falsch
diese ansicht und sie ist auch
gefährlich wenn wir virtuelle realität
mit dem rad zum gleich sitzen weil wir
dann hier wieder nur einer simulation
unterliegen und uns in einer scheinwelt
befinden und eine scheinwelt sollten wir
nicht als realität ausgeben das halte
ich für sehr gefährlich also das ist
ganz wichtig virtuelle realität ist mehr
als nur simulation weil sie nämlich
realität ist und nicht nur simulation
nicht nur scheint sondern sein wie wir
virtuelle realität
realisieren das ist genau die frage ja
jetzt leitet diese frage über zur frage
worin der ausgang aus der digitalen
unmöglichkeit bestätigt digitale
unmöglichkeit habe ich gerade versucht
zu erklären
wir könnten einen ausgang dadurch finden
aus der digitalen mündigkeit dass wir
das internet nicht nur also ein
instrument oder konsum medium verstehen
sondern als einen virtuellen
handlungsraum also nicht nur passive
konsumenten haltung
blasenbildung in youtube sich seine
üblichen videos vorschlagen die den
interessen entsprechen und nicht über
den virtuellen tellerrand hinausschauen
das ist eine digitale öffentlichkeit die
durch ki natürlich noch viel mehr
verstärkt wird weil sie unsere eigenen
ansätze der unmündigkeit natürlich
verstärkt und aufnimmt wir verstehen
unsere handlungen im internet nicht als
bloße simulationen dass wenn aus dann
die illusion oder fiktion sind als
virtuelle realitäten
für die wir verantwortung tragen es
betrifft natürlich wieder den ersten
punkt wenn wir das internet nur als
konsum medium ansehen dann treten wir da
als akteure ganz zurück wir nehmen nur
auf und werden dadurch abhängig wir
werden natürlich auch dadurch nicht
verantwortlich wir werden dann
verantwortlich wenn wir im internet
selbst agieren wenn wir selbst auch
etwas zur struktur des internets
beitragen und indem wir eben an dem
internet aktiv mitgestalten ist weiter
verknüpfen
vergrößern wir auch natürlich den
virtuellen handlungsraum also im
virtuellen handlungsraum zu handeln
bedeutet den virtuellen handlungsraum zu
vergrößern und nicht zu verkleinern das
ist ganz entscheidend also wir werden
dadurch auch immer freiheit das nie im
internet natürlich immer sinnvolle
informationen einspeisen verknüpfen und
nicht im talk mit modus uns abkapseln
das wäre eine verkleinerung des
virtuellen handlungs haut das ist ein
aus dem wir verstehen computerspiele
nicht nur das konsum medien und
intensive simulation einer scheinwelt
flight simulator sondern als form der
wirklichkeit reflexion ich bin darauf
auch eingegangen der eine der letzten
sitzung es geht darum dass wir
computerspiele kreativ einsetzen und uns
in neue situation denken und nicht nur
hier in eine scheinwelt flüchten das
wäre wie der digitale unmöglichkeit wir
verstehen die digitalisierung nicht als
beherrschen technik oder ökonomisches
schicksal sind als ermöglichen grund von
freiheit im sinne virtuelle realität
also wie es müssen die technik als eine
chance nutzen unsere freiheit kreativ zu
vergrößern und schließlich wir verstehen
das internet nicht als ein
privilegiertes konsum medium war es nur
manchen menschen auf der bild zur
verfügung steht nämlich uns hier zum
beispiel gerade in der besten welt
sondern als grundbedürfnis nach
freiheit auf welches alle menschen auf
der welt ein recht haben also auch da wo
es momentan kein internet gibt da
müssten die menschen einst in der tat
und dürfen weil es ihre freiheit
vergrößert um zur vergrößerung ihrer
würde damit auch bei trick das wären
verschiedene möglichkeiten des ausgangs
eine aus einer digitalen mündigkeit ja
worin besteht der öffentliche gebrauchte
digitalen vernunft verkannt kannte hatte
ja von dem öffentliche gebäude verläuft
in allen stücken gesprochen man könnte
zum beispiel die digitalisierung als
vernetzung und teilen von informationen
verstehen und zwar so dass wir eben
nicht nur information rezipieren sind
selbst ab information einspeisen
verknüpfen ordnen das wäre eine
möglichkeit dann die digitalisierung als
ermöglichung sgr und von freier mit
bestimmungen demokratie meinungsbildung
im internet kann dadurch vorangetrieben
werden
italy sierung als erweiterung unserer
freiheit virtualisieren
wir können dinge die wir vormals nur
physisch realisieren konnten wie zum
beispiel
informationsverarbeitung
informationsvermittlung wie auch
handlungsräume alle möglichen dinge
können wir durch die digitalisierung auf
neue weise realisieren und das
vergrößert unsere freiheit
ja das war jetzt ein kurzer ausblick auf
den öffentlichen gebrauch der vernunft
in der nächsten sitzung wird die
abschlusssitzung stattfinden und für
alle zuschauerinnen zuschauer gerne im
sinne der aktivität der digitalität
unter diesem video dann auf youtube
gerne rein posten welche dinge wir
besprechen zwar nicht nehmen die gerne
auf und kommen dann in der nächsten und
letzten sitzung darauf zu sprechen da
wünsche ich allen zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer noch eine schöne woche